[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondances sur Public Sénat
aujourd'hui focus sur l'un des secteurs
les plus polluants de notre économie la
mode un secteur en pleine mutation qui
tende de manière plus ou moins sincère
de ce verdir alors les nouveaux
étiquetage prévus par la loi peuvent-ils
rendre les marques plus vertueuses les
consommateurs sont-ils prêts à jouer le
jeu malgré un engouement toujours plus
grand pour la fast fashion réponse à la
fondatrice du cabinet utopie les marques
sont-elles prêtes à entamer leur
révolution verte reportage chez Okaïdi
qui multiplie ses efforts pour créer des
vêtements plus durables et puis pour
réduire l'impact carbone pourquoi ne pas
rapatriser l'activité ici en France
selon Guillaume Gibault le patron de
slip français qui sera notre invité les
planètes sont alignées pour relancer
l'industrie textile tricolore mais
d'abord tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur
l'empreinte carbone du secteur de la
mode c'est parti
la mode une industrie polluante c'est le
sixième secteur le plus polluant au
monde chaque année plus de 100 milliards
de vêtements sont vendus c'est 60% de
plus qu'il y a 15 ans et cette activité
n'est pas neutre 4 milliards de tonnes
de CO2 sont générés par an c'est plus
que tous les vols internationaux et le
trafic maritime réuni la mode c'est
aussi un gigantesque gashido oui pour
produire un jean il faut 7500 litres
d'eau pour un t-shirt 2500 litres soit
la consommation d'un Français en eau
potable pendant 17 jours résultat le
textile et le troisième plus gros
consommateur d'eau après la culture du
blé et du riz à ça il faut ajouter les
produits chimiques la mode est
responsable de 20% de la pollution d'eau
potable à cause des teintures et
produits de finition et une fois porté
nos vêtements continuent de polluer oui
le polyester la matière la plus utilisée
relâche à chaque lavage 240000 tonnes de
microplastiques qui finissent dans nos
océans l'équivalent de 24 milliards de
bouteilles plastiques et enfin de vie on
en fait quoi de nos vêtements on se
lasse vite 48 millions de tonnes sont
jetés chaque année dans le monde
en France nous jetons en moyenne 12 kg
de textile par habitant et par an
[Musique]
la mode est-elle prête à faire sa
révolution verte réponse avec vous
Elisabeth la ville bonjour bonjour Merci
d'être la fondatrice du cabinet de
conseil en développement durable
utopie on vient de le voir juste avant
l'industrie textile est très très
polluante et en même temps beaucoup
d'enseignes de plus en plus enseignes
disent aujourd'hui utiliser des matières
moins polluantes du coton durable des
matières recyclables ou recyclées et ce
qu'il faut les croire ces marques alors
il faut croire
à minimal intention la chose à regarder
c'est en fait le pourcentage de matière
dites durable parmi la totalité des
matières achetées donc quand on parlera
peut-être du Fashion pack tout à l'heure
qui est un engagement collectif
l'engagement pris par les marques c'est
25% de matières premières durables à
2025 mais quand on regarde une marque
très engagée comme picture qui fait des
vêtements un peu pour les sports outdoor
eux ils sont à 100% des vêtements qui
contiennent au moins 50% de matière
durable on a des entreprises comme Chloé
s'engage sur 90% de matière durables à
horizon de mémoire 2025 ou 2030 donc en
fait c'est le pourcentage première chose
à regarder qui compte évidemment il y a
la question de la matière aussi la
conception les modes de fabrication sont
très polluants énergivore et mettre des
gaz à effet de serre
là encore est-ce que les marques font
des efforts un tiers des marques et
proprement incapable de dire d'où
viennent les vêtements donc si vous
voulez travailler sur la partie
production il faut connaître non
seulement votre fournisseur direct mais
le fournisseur de fournisseur etc etc
avoir beaucoup d'informations et ces
informations là sont pas disponibles je
parlais de pitcher tout à l'heure qui
est une marque à outdoor eux ils ont
travaillé sur l'impact ils ont identifié
que la filature c'était je crois plus de
10% de leur bilan carbone donc de leur
impact sur le climat donc ils sont dit
il faut qu'on aille travailler on a un
filateur de coton à en Turquie la
Turquie c'est un pays où l'énergie
principale c'est du charbon donc ils ont
dit on va aller je crois qu'ils sont
associés Décathlon d'ailleurs pour faire
ça qui avait le même fournisseur
convaincre ce fournisseur de passer à
l'énergie solaire pour la moitié de ses
approvisionnements ce niveau de finesse
de travail il est il commence tout juste
dans l'industrie après il y a la
question en aval du recyclage on est
très en retard en France 48 millions de
tonnes de vêtements sont jetés pour le
pousser dans le monde chaque année si on
recycle le mieux on règle une partie du
problème ou pas en fait pas vraiment on
va peut-être en reparler mais le vrai
problème de l'industrie c'est ce qu'on
appelle la fast fashion c'est-à-dire les
volumes de production le nombre de
collections l'avalanche de promotion en
continu etc historiquement il y avait
deux collections par an aujourd'hui sur
certaines marques on est à plus de 5 ans
donc c'est c'est ça le problème
principal et donc dire on va résoudre ça
avec le recyclage il est nécessaire le
recyclage mais c'est une toute petite
partie je l'ai dit à la fin de vie c'est
une toute petite partie de l'impact
par ailleurs on recycle 1% à peu près de
ce qu'on met sur le marché chaque année
et ce qu'on met sur sur le marché chaque
année augmente de 4 à 5% par an donc
c'est pas le recyclage qui va résoudre
le problème de l'impact il faut le faire
mais avoir conscience que c'est une
partie d'un tout et plutôt une petite
partie d'un tout c'est intéressant Julia
fort c'est la marque loupe la plateforme
de la marque loom qui est très engagée
les accords de Paris là c'est clair la
production vestimentaire doit être
divisée par 3 d'ici 2050 j'ai du mal à
imaginer les marques se tirent une balle
dans le pied en réduisant autant leur
chiffre d'affaires leur volume à nouveau
c'est le sujet de la croissance des
croissances il faut être sélectif c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on veut voir croître et
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire décroître ce
qu'on voudrait faire des croître c'est
le un très grand volume de vêtements qui
augmente très vite qui sont vendus à
très bas prix dans des conditions
d'ailleurs environnementales et sociales
ce qu'on a pas parlé social douteuses et
donc c'est possible demain pour une
entreprise de avec un chiffre d'affaires
moindre de gagner plus d'argent si il y
a plus de marge sur les vêtements s'ils
sont plus qualitatifs s'ils sont vendus
plus cher etc vous pouvez en vendre
moins
de payer plus cher oui mais aujourd'hui
il y a un gaspillage vestimentaire comme
on a un gaspillage alimentaire on a je
crois que c'est Marks et Spencer qui
avait estimé ça en Europe 50% des
vêtements dont nous armoires qui sont
portés moins d'une fois par an donc la
question c'est dans l'avoir moins
peut-être des plus durable auquel on est
plus attaché qu'on fait réparer tout le
monde a son jean son pull fétiche etc on
en a pas besoin d'autant en fait c'est
ça le sujet après pour les marques à la
question des invendus qui sont souvent
détruits sauf que depuis le 1er janvier
2022 la loi AGEC interdit la destruction
des textiles invendus est-ce que les
marques jouent le jeu
pour la plupart évidemment parce que
toute façon elles n'ont pas le choix
puis vous vous souvenez il y avait eu le
scandale de burberries qui avait brûlé
des invendus etc donc en termes de
réputation c'est pas terrible et pour
cette raison là les marques ont quand
même anticipé d'ailleurs la mise en
application de la loi Ajax sur le volet
que vous évoquez aujourd'hui elles
jouent le jeu alors il y a eu des petits
scandales médiatiques aussi parce
qu'elles beaucoup d'invendus sont donnés
à des associations du coup finissent
dans les pays du Sud et en fait
finissent parfois dans des décharges sur
les plages au Ghana etc c'est pas
terrible non plus pour aider ou pour
contraindre les marques être plus
vertueuses depuis le 1er janvier encore
une fois en vertu de la Loi Ajac et
c'est pour ça qu'on fait cette émission
aujourd'hui sur l'industrie textile et
sur la Bible il y a ce nouvel étiquetage
qui est obligatoire les marques sont
censées donner tout un tas
d'informations sur la provenance des
produits est-ce que c'est effectif déjà
où est-ce qu'on est au tout début en
même temps laisse un peu le temps là on
est vraiment quelques jours après la
2023 il y aura un avant un après il y
aura un avant un après sachant que ça
concerne les marques qui font plus de 50
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
de mémoire les pièces qui font plus de
25000 pièces et les pièces nouvelles qui
seront mises en vente à partir du 1er
janvier autrement dit tout ce qui est en
magasin et en solde en ce moment n'est
pas concerné on a beaucoup parlé des
marques Elisabeth la ville j'ai envie de
dire les consommateurs maintenant dans
tout ça est-ce qu'il y a pas un
comportement
schizophrène je sais pas s'il faut le
dire comme ça des consommateurs qui
attendent des marques quand on les
interroge ils attendent des
consommateurs que les marques soient
engagés en faveur en faveur du climat du
développement durable et en même temps
la fast fashion fait un carton les
neuronaux science nous disent qu'on a
tous le cerveau un peu reptilien
derrière et le cerveau préfrontal ici
qui est capable de réfléchir de faire
des actes de consommation responsables
etc et qu'en fait ce que nous enseigne
le neuroscien c'est assez fascinant
c'est qu'on peut pas activer les deux
zones en même temps autrement dit si une
marque me parle comme si j'étais un peu
très fast fashion soucieuse d'avoir plus
de fringues pas cher alors c'est cette
partie là du cerveau qui s'active et une
fois que cette partie du cerveau est
activée je peux plus raisonner avec la
partie préfontral autrement dit quand on
dit oui mais les consommateurs veulent
que on a les consommateurs qu'on mérite
si les marques de mains parlent à
l'intelligence de chacun qui est en
chacun et ben elles auront des
consommateurs plus intelligents et elles
pourront mais évidemment il faut
pourront amener des actes qui vont plus
dans le sens de la consommation
responsable et faire des choix qui vont
moins dans le sens d'une espèce de fast
fashion freinetic en revanche elle peut
pas elles peuvent pas faire les deux
allez merci beaucoup Elisabeth Laville
font un triste du cabinet top et merci à
vous merci David on vient de le voir
l'industrie de la mode un impact
environnemental qui est absolument
phénoménal pourtant certaines marques
ont fait le choix de réagir reportage
notamment chez Okaïdi qui multiplie ses
efforts pour créer des vêtements plus
durables manuels avec 100 milliards de
vêtements produits chaque année
l'industrie textile serait responsable
de 10% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre dans le monde face à cette
situation alarmante 75% des Français
veulent plus de transparence sur la
provenance de leurs vêtements alors
depuis janvier 2023 la loi Haget impose
de nouvelles règles aux fabricants comme
par exemple indiquez si le produit
contient des matériaux recyclés s'il
rejette des microplastiques lors des
lavages mais aussi les pays de tissage
de teinture et de fabrication
un mois après l'entrée en vigueur de la
nouvelle réglementation les marques de
vêtements jouent-elles le jeu nous avons
rendez-vous avec Pierre diéno expert en
analyse environnementale et sociale
nous avons face à nous un pull de
l'ultra face fashion alors qu'est-ce que
l'ultra passage en deux mots c'est une
production effrénée donc très rapide et
à bas coût de produits qui sont d'un
premier abord attrayant qui respecte les
tendances les modes les nouvelles
mentions obligatoires sont accessibles
depuis un QR code présent sur
l'étiquette du vêtement un code-barre
que le client scanne avec son téléphone
portable
on peut regarder de plus près ce qui est
dit
très bien donc ce QR code une fois
scanné nous renvoie une page à vrai dire
blanche on espérait voir des
informations sur la trace à éviter sur
des allégations environnementales sur
des matières recyclées une composition
avec donc un détail mais ici nous avons
vraiment le niveau d'information le plus
basse c'est-à-dire vraiment à
composition brute cette entreprise de
l'ultra fastation et hors la loi
d'enfants de juridaire pour ce
manquement cette marque risquerait une
amende de 15000 euros mais pour les
professionnels du secteur cette nouvelle
réglementation est difficilement tenable
je pense que l'État les sanctionnera
mais la grosse question il faut pas se
le cacher c'est comment est-ce qu'on
contrôle même si vous avez une étiquette
d'une enseigne étrangère d'une marque
étrangère qui dit il y a 75% de recyclés
mon produit est parfaitement recyclable
je sais que ça a été fabriqué disons au
Vietnam
etc je sais que c'est durable etc
comment vous le vérifier
alors que certaines marques ont du mal à
se mettre au diapason d'autres ont au
contraire pris de l'avance
nous sommes à Roubaix chez Okaïdi une
grande marque de magasin de vêtements
pour enfants
l'entreprise ne se contente pas
uniquement d'appliquer la dernière
réglementation mais de s'aligner dès à
présent sur celle de 2024 qui imposera
aux marques de communiquer l'impact
environnemental de chaque vêtement via
un Ecoscore tous les consommateurs ont
envie d'en savoir plus ils ont envie de
comprendre ce qu'ils achètent alors ici
par exemple on a une doudoune qui a une
un impact environnemental de B ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que entre la
matière qui est en polyester recyclée et
sur toute la partie matelassage qui est
en polyester recyclée donc à base de
bouteilles recyclées on a gagné pas mal
d'impact carbone par rapport à ce qu'on
faisait avant d'où cette cotation B
alors ça coûte forcément un tout petit
peu plus cher par exemple typiquement le
coton bio ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
qu'un coton conventionnel un polyester
recyclé coûte aujourd'hui un peu plus
cher qu'un polyester normal mais pour
nous c'est vraiment prendre de l'avance
sur ces sujets là et il est pas question
aujourd'hui de de revenir et on doit
continuer à progresser évidemment en
gardant le prix
votre consommateur le plus attractif
possible la marque pour enfants c'est
également tourné davantage vers le
transport maritime 13 fois moins
polluant que le transport aérien
pour réduire leur impact sur
l'environnement les entreprises peuvent
donc agir sur les matières premières le
transport mais aussi les stocks
asphalte s'est fait connaître grâce à sa
démarche écologique consommer moins et
mieux une promesse qui résonne chez le
consommateur l'entreprise réalise un
chiffre d'affaires qui frôle les 25
millions d'euros
2016 d'un constat que l'industrie
textile produit énormément et beaucoup
ses produits finissent en stock
d'invendu en fin de saison donc la
solution qu'on a trouvé c'est de faire
de la précommande donc on ne produit que
ce qu'on a vendu un modèle économique
qui évite à l'entreprise le gâchis et
qui lui permet de faire des économies
sur le stockage
mardi on lance un nouveau produit en
précommande on laisse sur le site
pendant un mois les clients achètent sur
le site des vêtements qui n'existent pas
encore ils vont devoir prendre leur mal
en patience on retire le produit de la
vente on fait la synthèse de toutes les
quantités commandées par nos clients par
taille par couleur on envoie la commande
en usine la confection commence pas un
vêtement de plus ne sera fabriqué dans
les ateliers le client devra patienter
trois mois avant de recevoir son achat
qui dans la mesure du possible sera
fabriqué en France c'est l'un des
objectifs de la marque qui tentent
désormais de rapatrier une partie de sa
production pour certains de ses produits
phares
[Musique]
fabriquer du textile en France est aussi
le choix du slip français bonjour
Guillaume Gibaud merci d'être la
fondateur du slip français on parlera de
votre business évidemment juste après
mais d'abord je vais vous faire réagir
sur ce nouvel étiquetage prévu par la
loi GIEC depuis le 1er janvier les
marques doivent afficher la provenance
de leur produit et là on se dit que
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour toutes les
entreprises comme vous du textile qui
produisent en France c'est évidemment
une bonne nouvelle ça montre la
complexité d'une filière quand on va du
fil jusqu'au produit fini on se rend
compte qu'il y a beaucoup d'étapes et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui un vêtement ça
plus vraiment de prix en fait on en
trouve à tous les prix à 5 euros à 10
euros à 100 euros et aujourd'hui je
pense que dans le contexte
macroéconomique qu'on vit l'enjeu c'est
de raconter un produit qui est fait
localement qui crée de la valeur
économique qui crée des emplois qui
créent de la valeur sociale dans les
territoires et qui a évidemment un
impact carbone moindre puisqu'il est
fabriqué plus près cette étiquette
est-ce qu'elle va pousser ou c'est un
vœu pieux les marques à relocaliser en
France ou est-ce que ça peut contribuer
quand il y a une partie mais elle fait
partie de ce qu'on vit depuis 10 ans qui
a été accéléré par le covid évidemment
de se dire il y a une prise de
conscience générale des consommateurs
prêt à acheter un peu plus cher pour un
produit de meilleure qualité fabriqué
plus près de chez eux on sait que le
made in France est 90% des gens qui sont
prêts à fabriquer acheter français mais
ils sont prêts à payer 10 à 15 % plus
cher donc on voit qu'il y a voilà il y a
un gap entre les deux et c'est vrai
qu'ils sont prêts à payer 10 à 15 % plus
cher alors que ça coûte en réalité
plutôt 50 ou 70 % plus cher donc il
manque il manque un bon morceau de
pourcentage et c'est vrai que du coup
quand on arrive avec un étiquetage
obligatoire une mesure du bilan carbone
sur l'étiquette c'est autant d'éléments
qui font progresser les gens vers un peu
plus de d'informations sur leur choix de
voilà de se dire qu'aujourd'hui un
t-shirt qui vaut 5 euros dans une grande
enseigne la VS un t-shirt fabriqué
entièrement en France qui va valoir 35
euros le bilan carbone n'est pas le même
le bilan carbone d'ailleurs c'est un
t-shirt ça va être 10 kg par t-shirt
fabriqué ailleurs un t-shirt made in
France c'est 5 kg de CO2 donc voilà
c'est parti short ça peut être jusqu'à 5
kg des missions en moins après il y a
cette idée et c'est que ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher comment justement on
résout l'équation quand on interroge les
gens ils sont prêtés 10-15% plus cher
mais ça coûte en réalité un produit made
in France en textile 50% plus cher
ok il est meilleure qualité mais comment
on fait pour l'équation il y a
différentes choses il y a d'abord une
valeur d'usage de faire des produits qui
vont durer plus longtemps qu'on va
pouvoir réparer et puis après c'est un
argument marketing ou c'est vrai non ça
c'est vrai on mesure on fait les tests
labos et on voit bien que et quand on a
visité les textiles en français ailleurs
on voit bien qu'il y a plus de temps
passé plus de savoir-faire dans un
produit fabriqué localement avec un
secteur du textile français qui est en
grande difficulté aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'acteurs risquent de mettre la clé sous
la porte aujourd'hui le contexte est
très compliqué pour vous deux trois
chiffres dans les années 90 il y avait
700 000 emplois textiles et habillement
en France aujourd'hui c'est à peu près
une centaine de milliers donc on a perdu
80-85% des emplois en 30 ans parce qu'on
est parti fabriquer de plus en plus loin
pour de moins en moins cher puisque le
consommateur regardait pas trop et puis
voilà c'était pratique ça fonctionnait
très bien et puis il y a des gens aussi
bien voilà en Europe de l'Est en Afrique
du Nord en Asie qui ont exception
personnellement bien fait le boulot
commercial aussi pour aller attraper ces
volumes là donc aujourd'hui quand on
voit que le consommateur est prêt à nous
suivre comment est-ce qu'on peut
réindustrialiser s'appuyer sur des
marques comme la nôtre et aussi aussi
une nouvelle activité qu'on démarre sur
des acteurs plus importants qui soient à
la grande distribution puisque
aujourd'hui sont eux qui vendent le plus
de vêtements en France les marques de
luxe les marques de mode qui ont toutes
dans le contexte économique qu'on vit
actuel plus la loi Jacques arrive elles
ont toutes la préoccupation de
relocaliser de rapprocher une bonne
partie de leurs approvisionnements
certaines 3% d'autres 10% mais on est en
train de vivre se bousculement de marché
Guillaume Gibaud des vêtements made in
France vendus plus cher à vous écouter
c'est donc pas une fatalité il faut
investir dans des machines il faut
automatiser un maximum en même temps ça
veut dire moins d'emploi il faut il faut
faire un peu de tout pour donner leurs
idées en France on met sur le marché 3
milliards de vêtements par an donc ça
fait je crois que c'est quelque chose
comme 5000 pièces par minute donc à la
caisse de toutes les hypermarchés de
France et 5000 pièces minutes donc c'est
des volumes considérables on a tous 10
kg de fringues dans nos armoires donc
déjà il faut
produire moins mais mieux vraiment de se
dire ok on va penser un produit pour son
usage si on met peut-être le symbole des
hivers ou le chauffage vient peut-être à
manquer je sais pas des une polaire ou
une doudoune de se dire ok on va
fabriquer ce produit en pensant à
l'usage d'arrêter de se dire qu'on va
mettre des paillettes des strass des
doublement chez voilà revenir à l'usage
d'un vêtement pour fabriquer un vêtement
plus simple et là l'industrialiser
trouver le bon soutien industriel pour
industrialiser et industrialiser ça va
être automatisé certaines parties la
coupe par exemple quand vous avez le
rouleaux de tissu bah vous l'automiser
sur une machine numérique avec voilà et
avec un outil français génial qui permet
de gagner beaucoup de temps de découpe
et après garder de l'agilité et donc du
travail de la main de l'emploi avec des
gens qu'on va former qui sont des
métiers manuels sur certaines opérations
et être en fait dans une agilité encore
une fois sur un produit dont on a pensé
l'usage où on va industrialiser on a
toujours le savoir-faire en France
certains disent qu'on a perdu nos
compétences dans le textile notre
savoir-faire avec les destructions de
poste dont on a parlé que notre appareil
industriel et sinistré il avait dit on a
perdu 80% des objectif en 20 ans et ça
c'est une vraie réalité aujourd'hui il y
a encore les voilà un vrai bastion de
résistant conçu voilà s'adapter avec le
temps moi je l'ai vraiment vécu pendant
l'épisode des masques et du covid qui a
été un élément assez structurant pour
notre filière on l'a tous vu dans la
presse un trou de masque pas assez de
masque voilà catégorie catégorie 2 en
tout cas la filière textile française
c'est mobilisé dès le début du premier
confinement pour fabriquer des masques
et à montrer au grand public elle était
capable en quelques jours de mettre au
point un produit quand même assez
technique avec cette histoire de
filtration respirabilité tout ça et de
fabriquer des centaines de millions moi
je j'ai coordonné au sein du réseau
façon de faire donc j'étais le premier
président de la fabrication de 200
millions de masques et 12 millions de
blues et là on a vu c'est des dizaines
de milliers de salariés qui sont revenus
au boulot dans des conditions voilà
aujourd'hui si on a un peu de recul mais
à l'époque les premiers jours de du
confinement c'était quand même pas
et on a vu que cette filière était
capable du jour au lendemain de
fabriquer des volumes industriels par
milliers par centaines de milliers et de
se mettre en ordre de batailles sur un
produit assez complexe mais en tout cas
elle a la capacité de d'avancer derrière
il y a eu plein de relancer plus de 700
projets plan de relance du gouvernement
qui ont été déployés dans la filière
donc il y a l'innovation il y a des
nouvelles générations d'entrepreneurs
de relocaliser de plus en plus alors
tout ou partie de la chaîne de
production évidemment et nous l'enjeu
est moi le débat que je la vision que je
porte c'est de se dire on pourra pas
relocaliser 100% des productions
textiles à 24 mois ou même plus mais si
par contre on se dit on va chercher ne
serait-ce que 5% des volumes de
vêtements fabriqués en France et cela
leur localise à 24 mois là on
reconstruit sérieusement une filière
aujourd'hui c'est 3% des vêtements des 3
milliards de vêtements seulement 3% sont
fabriqués en France si on arrive à faire
passer ce chiffre de 3 à 5 à 18 mois on
sera tous déjà très content et ça nous
permet de voilà de renforcer les
entreprises existantes de remplir les
cartes de commande de mettre des
possibilités d'investissement en
et je pense qu'on a de quoi redémarrer
une filière efficace merci beaucoup
Guillaume fondateur du slip français
merci à vous alors on l'a vu les marques
sont toujours à la recherche de nouveaux
matériaux toujours plus innovants et
Green focus sur une nouvelle matière qui
nous vient et oui de nos pâturages
[Musique]
fabriquer une robe avec du lait l'idée
sans le saugrenu pourtant c'est très
sérieux bonjour Émilie alors le Centre
national de l'économie laitière et le
centre européen des textiles innovants
sont en passe de réussir un pari assez
fou l'ancienne à partir de l'air et oui
face à l'urgence climatique à la mode
recherche sans cesse des nouvelles
matières plus responsables et est l'un
des oreilles du côté de la nature alors
vous avez par exemple la toile
d'araignée qui pourrait devenir une
alternative à la soie la pomme qui
remplace déjà le cuir chez certaines
marques vegan on peut également citer le
pissenlit comme caoutchouc nouvelle
génération et donc aujourd'hui le lait
ou plus précisément la protéine de lait
qui s'appelle la caséine et l'idée n'est
pas nouvelle elle remonte à
l'entre-deux-guerres exactement alors
dans les années 30 un sinistre italien
parvient à transformer donc cette
fameuse protéine de lait en fibres il va
se lancer dans la fabrication de
vêtements notamment pour les blessés
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale le
problème c'est qu'il utilise beaucoup de
d'adjuvants chimiques du coup son fils
devient cassant et friable et finalement
il abandonne le projet jusqu'à ce qu'il
réapparaisse dans les années 2000
exactement alors ces deux sociétés
italienne et une Allemande qui
redécouvre ce procédé lors ils utilisent
moins de solvants chimiques mais
toujours un peu et il faut attendre 2020
pour que des Français reprennent le
procédé pour le rendre totalement green
alors c'est français ce sont deux
acteurs qui a priori n'avaient rien à
rien en commun il s'agit du CNIL qui
représente les professionnels du lait en
France et le Setti qui est le centre de
recherche européen du textile innovant
c'est un peu le choix entre deux mondes
racontez-nous cette rencontre exactement
alors le Kennel au départ l'idée vient
lui c'est il souhaite valoriser en fait
le lait impropre à la consommation il
faut savoir que 7000 tonnes de lait par
chaque année à la poubelle alors pas
parce qu'il est périmé tout simplement
parce qu'il ne répond pas à certains
critères de production du coup pour
lutter contre ce gâchis se dit tiens
pourquoi pas la mode il contacte le Sety
et ensemble ils y mettent au point donc
ce fameux procédé totalement propre
alors quel est ce procédé comment
transforme le lait en vêtement alors
j'ai envie de vous dire qu'au début
c'est un petit peu comme le fromage en
fait on va on va d'abord isoler la
protéine de lait on va y ajouter un
acide on va ensuite faire sécher cette
préparation qui va devenir une poudre à
laquelle on va ajouter un sol en vert le
mélange est alors plongé dans un bain de
coagulation la matière coagulle et magie
vous obtenez un fil un fil à partir
duquel et bien vous allez pouvoir
fabriquer des pelotes des bobines et
donc du tissu incroyable à quoi ce qu'il
ressemble ce tissu est-ce qu'il a la
couleur du lait j'espère pas
d'odeur du tout je vous rassure côté
couleur il ressort sous un joli blanc
crémeux mais peut tout à fait être teint
sa fibre est 12 confortable et peut-être
portée aussi bien l'hiver que l'été
sinon il est bas anti- antibactérien
antistatique hypoallergénique et même
biodégradable et compostable c'est quand
même assez exceptionnel pour un pour un
tissu il est également très résistant et
thermorégulant mais la belle surprise
David c'est son rendu fluide léger
soyeux rafraîchissant comme de la soie
et d'ailleurs il a tout de suite séduit
le célèbre créateur mosit Traoré qui a
fait sensation à la dernière Fashion
Week avec donc des créations à base de
les créations qui d'ailleurs ont été
vendues à l'automne dernier au printemps
à Paris c'est génial tout ça la filière
française dans tout ça justement le
criminel et le tout est quasi prêt le
Setty a investi dans une machine très
performante qui va lui permettre un
tissage à grande échelle le lieu il est
déjà choisi ce sera Roubaix l'ex
capitale du textile qui d'ailleurs en
train de renaître de ses cendres en ce
moment avec tout un tas de projets made
in France éco-responsable et puis la
Normandie devrait également suivre avec
à terme des fibres au bon lait de
Normandie donc vous voyez tout se fait
au niveau local avec l'idée toujours de
développer l'activité dans des bassins
laitiers est-ce que c'est rentable de
fabriquer des vêtements en fibre de lait
alors ce qui coûte cher pour l'instant
c'est le solvant la matière première
elle on en a un profusion je vous disais
7000 tonnes de lait par an pour un litre
une tonne de lait il faut compter 16 kg
de fil et 61 61 mètres des tof l'idée
maintenant donc c'est d'industrialiser
le procédé pour vite le rentabiliser
mais on va pas se mentir David c'est
vrai que c'est ces vêtements en fibre de
lait sont des produits quand même
Premium qui qui sont à mi-clan on va
dire entre la laine qui est vendu 4
euros le kilo et la soif vendu 62 € le
kilo bon maintenant les marques est-ce
qu'elles sont prêtes à se lancer ben
écoutez lors de sa présentation au
secteur en juin dernier les la fibre de
lait a fait sensation du côté du
prêt-à-porter également de la haute
couture mais aussi de la face fashion
alors des discussions très avancées
seraient actuellement en cours mais pour
l'instant rien n'est officiel donc c'est
pour ça que le Cécile ne souhaite pas
donner de marque en tout cas si ça
marche ça sera un cercle véritablement
vertueux le lait ne terminera plus à la
poubelle l'éleveur lui au lieu de jeter
à perdre touchera une rémunération de
l'ordre de 20 centimes par litre de lait
et puis la mode pour raconter sur une
matière 100% compostable et
biodégradable et Green bien sûr avec
cerise sur le gâteau une nouvelle
filière en France et donc des emplois à
la clé ainsi tout le monde serait
gagnant exactement merci Émilie voilà
c'est la fin de pourvu que ça dure
l'émission qui rend les cours
responsable sur Public Sénat émission à
voir ou revoir sur Public Sénat le
replay c'est toujours plus
missionnaire.fr nous on se retrouve dans
deux semaines
[Musique]